result of spending years in the space
identifying pain points whether they be
around sustainability like I grew up
hating pads most pads have enough
plastic for like three to five plastic
bags right so very scratchy very
comfortable but also wanting a period
positive gender inclusive brand so we
are August wanting a gender inclusive
name on the back it says we're here for
everyone who menstruates and I think
especially in this age of transphobia it
really means a lot to us to be proudly a
gender inclusive brand but everything
about the product we try to be super
thoughtful about from how we design it
to be as comfortable as absorbent as
possible but also as sustainable as
possible